das hat man das spezial es gab es des
bundesheeres steht bis auf der arbeit
wir haben aufträge zu lande zu wasser in
der luft und wir haben hier zu lande und
zu luft dargestellt haben hier hinter
mir das wissen fahrzeugs an sie
verstehen was natürlich auch immer ein
publikumsmagnet ist und hier ist ein
dass japan mando bei der station zum
angreifen
und weil man doch die ganzen geräte
dürften des anflugs ganze interessant
die chance april zu weil immer gern
vielleicht hätten das gibt und einfach
mitterbauer kollegen ja gemeinsam mit
den punkt den bürgerdiensten auch
geleistet haben und mal spricht einfach
gern immer wieder darüber waren eure
geschichten
frauen können alles machen was männer
auf marco können also sind frauen sich
auch gute panzer fahrerinnen
es gibt natürlich die klassischen fragen
wie die ausbildung zum militärpiloten
abläuft uns freuen wir uns natürlich war
jetzt zur zeit beheben nachsuchen dass
möglichst viele sich interessieren dafür
dann gibt es natürlich technische fragen
zum gerät selbst das immer wieder
auftauchende beispiel ist die diese zwei
spitzen die wir unser hubschrauber oben
hat das ist die klassische nationalparks
frage dass sein cable kader für das und
sich in eine hochspannungsleitung
fliegen und werden die halt gehabt
wir zeigen heute militärelite kontakt
boxen
dieser ganze neue sportart im heeres
sportzentrum als zubringer leistung für
den nahkampf eine damit er schon
grundfertigkeiten selbstverteidigung und
wir machen heute mit einem trainerkurs
aus allen teilen österreichs die
ausgebildet wurden im internet kontakt
zu machen alleine fort eine vorführung
entstand ist ganze durch die
attraktivierung des grundwehrdienstes
als ehre sportzeitung hat mit
leistungssportler 1500 unbedingt
ausgebildet und da und ein militärelite
kontakt sind mittlerweile gibt es diese
sportart seit drei jahren und werden
alle 150 übungsleiter ausgebildet ist
ein ganz erneuert system macht spaß
konditioniert und ist schuld eine der
grundfertigkeiten das soll dann selbst
verteidigen
die berufssoldaten werden ausgebildet
als multiplikatoren als trainer
es gibt bereits in straß bei dem jeder
der rund 17 es gibt in retz die boxerin
kosovo grundwehrdiener boxen
das ist das ziel konditionieren mit spaß
mit freude und waren dann aber
selbstverteidigung dabei ist dann freut
man sich ersparen
mannschaftssport
nein
frau
roddick